well Kevin Hart and an eco parish are
already honeymooning and st. Bart's a
beautiful bride a gorgeous Beach so what
the heck is Kevin doing inside a sweaty
gym one wait wait wait wait hold on this
doesn't feel right okay here we go
what - Kevin Hart honest honeymoon got
the Eastwood in his backyard Ludacris in
front of a live audience so what's the
deal with all the push-ups Faris and
Chris Pratt we're responding to will
dodge at Canadian outlaw 22 push-up
challenge to raise awareness for the 22
men and women who commit suicide every
day our veterans well similar to the ice
bucket challenge which dominated social
media and raise money for ALS research
the 22 push-up challenge is hoping to
talk in 22 million push-ups to raise
awareness for veterans let's do him drop
and give me 20 - Chris pass the baton to
the rock and John Krasinski and that's
when things officially took a turn from
six packs to four-legged friends
I think be more dork
don't get mad me then you did nothing my
challenge now goes out to mr. Chris
Evans Captain America I had some trouble
with his furry sidekick Thanks